in a world where the u.s faces two major
revisionist powers russia and china
and threats from the likes of isis iran
and north korea
a critical edge for america is its
global network of allies and strategic
partners
as the national defense strategy states
it's an advantage that no competitor or
rival can match
it's an advantage more important than
ever while the security environment has
grown more complex over the past decade
the overall size of american military
has remained largely the same
that's not likely to change in the wake
of the pandemic the u.s defense budget
will remain flat
or even might be cut hence understanding
what allied militaries such as the uk or
japan can bring to the table
is now more important than ever knowing
allied capabilities and their shortfalls
is essential if american strategists are
to effectively plan on how to deter our
enemies
and keep the peace the policy of the
united states might be america first
but it can't be america alone
to learn more about the current state of
allied militaries click the link to the
new edition in my
edited volume a hard look at the hard
power assessing the defense capabilities
of allies and strategic partners
and let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to like and subscribe for
more research and videos from aei